[Music]
happy life day everybody in celebration
of this festive time of year I rewatched
this Star Wars Holiday Special
[Music]
Star Wars Holiday Special aired on TV in
1978 one time it was never a broadcast
or released on home video but
unfortunately in the era of the Internet
it's very easy to find I bought it on
eBay about 10 years ago and I've seen it
way more times than I care to admit the
original cast is in it George Lucas had
nothing to do with it he even once
reportedly said if I had time and a
sledgehammer I would track down every
copy of that show and smash it so the
movie starts with a cold open the
Millennium Falcon flying through space
but the Imperials are after them because
they have got to get Chewbacca home to
his life planet of Kashyyyk for a life
day it's apparently a very important
holiday that he would never miss
Chewbacca would never miss a life day
and then the intro Chewbacca's family
his wife mala his father Ichi and his
son lumpy lumpy and we just get what
feels like six years of mindless wookie
dialogue with zero subtitles a lot of
times you're watching like like a film
and you don't know what they're saying
but you can kind of discern it with body
language and cues like that but not in
the holiday special it she goes over to
this like chess board and just watches a
bizarre Cirque de Soleil performance for
two and a half minutes football time and
that's basically what this whole movie
is like it's just they come up with a
bunch of cool stuff and then they just
go from like section to section showing
off these weird 70s gadgets that kind of
feel like they would have been in Star
Wars lore it's very confusing at this
point we are a full 12 minutes into the
movie and we finally get our first line
of dialogue and it's from Luke and he's
like oh look it's Chewbacca's family in
the year after Episode four does Luke
like really get to know Zhu bakas family
because what what he knows like
everything about them he's like
Chewbacca would never miss a life day
but that's not even the most weird thing
about the scene it's the way that Luke
looks in this scene Luke looks like his
makeup was done by a mortician it's very
scary if I had never seen a Star Wars
movie and this was the first thing I was
seeing I would definitely think that
Luke is the villain he's not there now
they're way overdue that's terrifying
alright so at this point we're about six
hours into the movie and mala is gonna
make some bantha stew or something
bantha surprise and is using this
cooking video to learn how to make it
sidenote how don't wookies cook without
getting fur in everything because we
know they shed so they just eat their
own fur just something to think about
anyway and then the worst character
shows up his name is son Dan and he's
like this really annoying traitor
and not like traitor is in like traitor
as in like tra de re like trades things
and he's got a ton of gadgets he shows
you this like video that's gonna be an
experience and you get the vibe that
it's about to get really weird and then
it does I am you experience experience
[Music]
I am your pleasure no I mean together
this is our moment together in time yeah
yeah what is that the first time I
watched this movie was with my dad my
dad got up and left and it goes on for
like a full six minutes six minutes of
this anyway then we get Princess Leia
like hanging out with c-3po for some
reason and she gets a call from Chuy's
wife mala and she's like so good to see
you and I'm like a thousand percent sure
that they don't know each other and then
she's like I don't actually want to talk
to you can you put chewier Han on I
don't want to tart the channels so could
you do me a favor and send to either
Tubac or Han Solo to the screen please
and she's like mom's not here and Leia I
was like huh that's weird
then Han and Chewie arrived on Kashyyyk
and the Wookiees are like so stoked but
then it's not Han and Chewie
it's Imperial Stormtroopers and they're
at the door and they're coming to search
for what are they doing the only
variables or something I don't know what
they're even doing they're very rude and
they're like break Lumpy's laptop and
then Sundance shows up and invites them
to stay and then he screams at mala for
some reason it breaks out more gadgets
of course and then one of them is a
performance by Jefferson Starship
Jefferson Starship it launches into a
full music video from Jefferson Starship
I don't know why it goes on for five
minutes and then the Imperials continue
to search the house for whatever they're
searching for and lumpy opens up another
trinket which is a cartoon about his dad
Chewbacca and Han Solo but the craziest
part about this cartoon that aired in
1978 it was the introduction of Boba
Fett on screen this weird holiday
special is the first time that we meet
Boba Fett Boba Fett Boba Fett the best
bounty hunter in the galaxy and he's
like their ally and portrays them this
is arguably the only like good part of
the
well it's the best part it's not
necessarily good but it is a crazy thing
but they just just straight up intro
bobafet uh so yeah I know it feels like
we're jumping from thing to thing but
that's literally what this whole movie
is TV special whatever they jump to this
weird transmission where they're like
hey everybody we're gonna show you life
on Tatooine so that you can feel better
about your life by comparison because
Tatooine is horrible like imagine if
they did that so then they cut to the
Mos Eisley cantina which has B Arthur in
1978 ain't a Star Wars special where she
has a musical number let that sink in
Bea Arthur has a musical number in Star
Wars
[Music]
a musical number with Bea Arthur in a
Star Wars movie we're back to Kashyyyk
for some reason and then Schumacher
shows up and the stormtroopers are kind
of going after lumpy and he's like stay
away from me and my son and then Han
Solo shows up and somehow gets the
stormtrooper to like Willam screen mouth
the balcony they use the wilhem scream
it's great so I guess all is well now
because the the Wookiees have this long
Rory reunion that goes on for what feels
like 20 minutes I don't know I fell
asleep at this point and then they start
celebrating life day which they put on
red robes and they hold orbs and then
they just kind of walk in single file I
really know what's happening here it's
kind of creepy but all the Wookiees are
in some kind of foggy church and then
c-3po and r2d2 were there for some
reason and then Leia and Han and Luke
show up and then c-3po is like I wish I
were a real boy r2 and I wish that we
were more than just mechanical beings so
that we could share your feelings with
you and then Leia breaks into a
beautiful song like honestly Carrie
Fisher singing voice pretty nice pretty
nice
[Music]
and then we're back in their home on
Kashyyyk and they're all holding hands
and praying and the wikis are roaring
and they're praying and then it's over
so that was about 16 hours long I think
it feels like I don't know it's all the
whole thing feels what I assume is what
an acid trip feels like it wouldn't no
it's not so bad it's good it's not so
Star Wars that you can respect it it's
just a thing that exists that happened
have you guys seen the holidays special
if so let me know your favorite part
and by favorite I mean most tolerable
part and like comment subscribe all that
stuff and I will see you guys in the new
year happy life day